all right welcome everybody so we're
really excited because we have four
great speakers today
to take part take part in your source
semiannual lightning talk as always like
to acknowledge numb focus we're
sponsoring this event TD Ameritrade for
offering up this venue and obviously
Midas at the University of Michigan for
the food that you are enjoying here
important points for people who are new
here first thing is emergency exits
there's one right over here and one
right out to the doors that you enter
through on your right
we're always soliciting for speakers
although this year we've been pretty
lucky
we're booked out to about November right
now so we're doing pretty well uh but
always give us feedback I got some
feedback about food earlier which I love
right
also check out our github page so of
anything that were that we shared here
the slides get posted as well unless
there are quick questions actually
actually for today's lightning talk
let's hold the questions to the end so
there's will see about seven minutes or
so lightning talk so hold your questions
to the end you'll have enough time and
please remember that you're in a
borrowed space so do clean up after
yourselves the trash is over my weather
weather garb the garbage cans are over
by where the food is I'd like to read
our PI data code of conduct pi data is
dedicated to providing an harassment
free meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
race or religion we do not tolerate
harassment of meeting participants in
any form all communication should be
appropriate for professional audience
including people of many different
backgrounds sexual language and imagery
is not appropriate for any of our meet
up events be kind to others do not
insult or put down other attendees
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist relations ring
SACEUR exclusionary jokes are not
appropriate for pi data attendees
violating these rules may be asked to
leave the meetup at the sole discretion
of the meetup organizers but overall
thank you for making this a inviting
experience for everybody
so a quick icebreaker so we're gonna
allude to who we have for our talk next
month with this icebreaker so please
turn to you to somebody on your left or
you're right introduce yourself and tell
them if you use numpy scifi or what's
that it's part of the Python data
science stack so the reason why I asked
your next creative
what do you
in what language is that
all right we're back we're back thank
you so it's always that hopefully you've
met somebody new that you haven't tried
it with before this with ins data
science it's not really a big of a news
but people who are you doing about deep
learning cafe to has now been integrated
into hi George so if you have a cafe to
pull requests that actually goes into pi
torch now it depends on your usage but
from what I've heard Kathy is better for
developers if you're developing like
deep learning models and you want to
deploy them to iOS Android it's really
good for that versus and pipe towards it
really allows you to build your models
quickly and experiment as well TD
Ameritrade is hiring so if you want to
check out our jobs paid job Satya murti
cog and also chat with Logan ahlstrom
who's standing right up over here
his team is hiring a data scientist is
all the data analysts so please reach
out to him
also at announcement that there's a new
meet-up in town with that dug lands over
here
so he's running the Michigan Python
meetup group so I do sign up and check
it out there's a lot of potential
synergies between our two groups and as
I spoke about earlier why I asked about
numpy CyHi is because next month we have
Travis olefin who is I guess the creator
of numpy and principal or original
author of the Syfy package he's going to
be here next month talking about XMD it
crossed language set of libraries for
general typed containers I think that
will be a great talk with Travis so with
that we welcome our first speaker and
this is William Murphy and he's gonna be
talking about projection software for DJ
DJ IA and all other stocks and
commodities okay your seven-minute
starts now
okay in the 1960s an aerospace engineer
named James Marshall Hurst got
interested in the market to use Fourier
analysis in a comb of digital filters to
break down the data into his basic
building blocks
he figured out how they went together
and came up with a mathematical and
conceptual model that explains every
movement of all stocks all commodities
financial futures index so that in there
is absolute proof of what he found is
true and here's my computer won't give
us very many charge but he says they're
tight you could take this out he says
that all stocks and commodities having
cycles in them or waves so if you will
look here we say this is day 1 2 3 4 5 6
1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 kind of 6 so
there's a sixth day working within an 18
day cycle working within the bigger
probably a third six-day cycle explains
all this the trouble is there's no way
to get to the end there today if I was
analyzing this mathematically I would be
you know back here that's where the
relationship went in so I can't get the
name so I've been trying to Rack my
brains for 25 years crying because this
thing is worth 100 million dollars maybe
I'm trillion I don't know because every
stock does this I don't know
[Music]
there's another one scroll down the only
difference between stocks is the trend
they still will have a little six day
you see a little six day another six
days six days working within a bigger
one and all the stocks all commodities
all indexes have the same thing and so
it it gives you the possible to
understand what's going on and to be
able to predict it because it will tell
you ahead of time
the market will tell you ahead of time
what its gonna do
I'll give you hints and will tell you
exactly but it gives you enough so when
you think we have a hundred options call
options for one for April at 25th
then we'll have 100 or 50 to 100 call
options and fifty two hundred put
options which you can play just one and
that's just one thing you got a May June
so they just that one stock and when you
think if goes up to pretend you'll get
maybe five thousand percent movement in
one of those options so being able to do
that so we'll give you possibilities and
I didn't think I mean I can say I've
been fighting this for 25 years it's
crazy
I'm almost a four years old and I'm
going to kick the bucket or me and
this knowledge is going to be lost okay
this is the Compaq Computer clmp
whatever it doesn't matter it's still
not the waves working within bigger way
bigger way watching with a whole bigger
wave this is unbelievable
now the problem is like I say how do you
overcome that you mathematically you
can't get to the end of the data but you
can get a thought of making any
projection model do what I - a non-ideal
sine wave summation wave and then
companies off and switching it until it
does actually fit this and then you can
then project but it's tough because you
for trying to do it in your mind you
have you got to think of well it's 27
days along in a 35 day going down well
this is 16 days along a 47 days going up
and you know it would probably get crazy
you might be able to deal with the group
but one person it would be really tough
like I say I have car chair if anybody's
interested it's crazy that I'm going to
you know kick the bucket one of these
days and all this information is gone
because I'm there's nobody else in the
world that knows what I know
because have you heard of any of these
mutual funds making 500,000 pretending
here no it's possible with this and
there's absolutely proof I've got 50
different stock charts they're all the
same period so do you know should be I
guess technical analysis do you combine
fundamental I mean also such as to seek
out whether poems okay no it's just
fundamental to know you know it's
probably good to know if you're doing a
like a health care company or something
where if they get yeah cuz I've seen
there was one company that was trading
at forty seven dollars and it opened in
the next morning at 27 and I always
thought that there would be an
indication that's the insiders would
know and would be dumping it and then it
would crash well it's not true because
it was going fine doing all it's saying
that it crashed but see even with
something like that
you can have you know a lot of money
foot which would save you even if you're
doing this and it crashes you can make
more money on that out of you know ten
or twenty puts the maybe cost you two
dollars or five dollars you make ten
thousand dollars on them if you lose
five thousand up here on the calls but
so there's no way if you do it right
understand it and project correctly it's
unbelievable great let's thank William
again so up next we have Chris gates
will be talking to us about that snake
make for data analysis
so thanks Shawn thank you
how many people here have heard of snake
make let's see show of hands
a couple people one a couple people that
I know okay um how many people here are
using snake make okay it was a proper
subset so that's good so let me start by
telling you why I use snake make so I'm
the lead software engineer at the
University of Michigan bioinformatics
core I work with about ten other data
analysts and we try to help I ologists
identify and interpret patterns in DNA
and in practice what that means is we
take a large amount of genomic input
data and then we run them through a
chain of bioinformatics tools to try to
make sense of them
and often we automate that chain of
bioinformatics tools into a process
called a scientific data workflow now
over the last few years we've been using
snake make more and more because snake
make is a framework that makes it easier
to build and execute data workflows so
before we took it to snake make I don't
want to consider a traditional data
workflow and I could dazzle you with a
really cool arcane bioinformatic
workflow but we're going to keep it
really simple right now and all we're
gonna do is we're going to transform a
raw chicken into fried chicken and we're
gonna do that very simply with a bash
script this bash script has three
important steps i marinate the chicken
in the buttermilk i bread the chicken
and then i fry the chicken it's very
simple and as a workflow there's one
input which is the raw chicken and
there's one output which is the fried
chicken
you guys are staring at this like it's
the rosetta stone like the truth is in
there it's just fried chicken does your
chicken look like that sorry so okay so
this is how this would work in a bash
script a traditional traditional
workflow let's take a look at how a
snake make would handle this so first
off instead of a bash script snake make
use of something called a snake file a
snake file is a text file that defines
the workflow uses a very simple markup
to define rules and each rule describes
how to create output files from input
files now this these three rules mirror
the bash script and in fact this
like kind of a wordy version of the bass
script we just saw but we're not done
because in addition snake make also
declares all the input files and all the
output files for each rule so instead of
having a single input for the workflow
and a single output for the workflow we
now have inputs for each rule and
outputs for each rule that becomes very
important because in this way the snake
file defines the dependencies for all
the input files and all the output files
and it so defines the relationships that
connect different rules okay that's what
the snake file does so now we can talk
about what snake make as a whole does so
snake make is a program happens to be a
Python program that interprets the snake
file against the files in the file
system and then it executes the rules as
necessary to produce the output that you
asked for so when you execute snake make
like you see on the right you just
invoke a snake make and in your snake
file you said you wanted Fried Chicken
so snake make figures out well to get a
Fried Chicken I have to execute the fry
rule and before that I have to execute
the bread rule and before that I have to
execute the marinade rule and that
pattern that declarative pattern it's
very very powerful because I never have
to say I need to execute the bread or I
need to execute the marinade I just tell
it what I want to end up with and snake
make figures out what it has to do
because it can because you already
expressed that in your snake file that
declarative pattern also has a couple of
really nice consequences for one it's
really easy to extend snake make to
handling new inputs variations on a
theme so we can start with getting
buttermilk fried chicken but it's very
trivial to change that snake file to
then extend it so that we can also get a
lemon herb marinated fried fish it's
very very trivial and it doesn't change
the structure of your snake file very
much at all another thing is that snake
make is very durable and I mean durable
in the sense of a database is durable it
crashes well I've never gotten snake
maker per se to crash but a lot of the
tools that I invoke bioinformatic tools
crashed all the time they are very flaky
so when snake make crashes it's going to
delete any files that we're
complete in this way whenever snake
makes stops if a rule is executed you
know it succeeded and if it didn't
succeed It was as if the rules never run
now that's really nice right out of the
gate but it also means that once I go in
there and I fix the problem two restarts
think make I just type snake make again
and it picks up exactly where it left
off because it knows what it needs to do
and in fact at any point I can ask snake
make what have you done and what's left
to do and this diagram here on the right
was something that I generated by typing
snake make with us with a flag and it
just generated that diagram another
thing that's really nice about snake
make is that it's computationally
efficient if you consider a traditional
pipeline like the shell script that we
looked at at first and let's say that we
had a set of inputs which I'll call
input a and that that workflow had four
different tasks each of those shaded
areas as a task some of those tasks are
going to be quick like the first task
but some of them are going to take a
little bit longer like the second task
also each of these tasks has a certain
resource footprint it needs a lot of
memory or needs a little memory well
when you put it all together and you
think about well how much time am I
going to need to execute this you have
to sum up the lengths of all the tasks
but then when you think of how many how
much resource do I need to execute this
you have to take the maximum width of
any of the tasks now what that creates
in this diagram is white space what it
creates in your life is waste that's
wasted time and it's wasted compute
resources and it gets worse if you have
to execute a series of inputs which we
often do so
snake make because it understands the
relationship of all the rules and the
relationship of all the inputs and
outputs it knows how to paralyze all the
jobs and it does a fantastic job in a
very efficient job of paralyzing all of
your rules also it understands the idea
of resource constraints so that you can
do that intelligently and it can commit
only the resources that you need it's
always faster and it's always more
efficient this is really nice snake make
is portable so if I want to run it on my
workstation
I run the snake make if I want to run it
somewhere else I just add a flag and
it's going to work
it runs on all the operating systems and
it's compliant with docker and Conda
so in general I could build out
something that did something as well as
snake make but the truth of the matter
is I really just want to focus on the
data flow and snake make enables me to
focus on the data flow and leave all
those mechanics have meta intelligence
to the side and attend to them only if I
need to so I like snake make if it's
interesting to you I'd be happy to talk
with you about it that's not limited to
simple pipelines yeah and I'd be happy
to answer any questions you have
anything thank you okay a quick pro con
versus plain make so snake make is
spiritually built on top of make I mean
it's not actually implemented on top of
make but it was inspired by make and so
make is your go-to you know it's a go-to
tool if you're doing less c-word earlier
really if anything but so what snake
make does that make doesn't do there's
actually three things one is that the
wild carding system and snake make is a
lot more intuitive than it is in make so
it's really easy to figure out what's
going on second thing is that with snake
make you can declare multiple outputs
okay the third thing is that snake make
has that job submission built in so if
you want to something to work on your
laptop and then you want to drop it on
to a cluster you have to change your
snake file at all which is really sweet
the other thing is that I lied a little
bit when I said that the snake file was
a text file it looks like a text file
but it's actually a Python file so
anything you can express in Python you
can teach snake make how to do and
that's pretty powerful yeah was there a
question on your left there yeah this is
this is a it's the question is - snake
make draw this this job graph and it
does this is a general gist generated by
snake make yep so let's thank Chris
again take it
so next up we have Maureen Metzger she's
gonna be talking to us about
introduction to the fast AI deep
learning library for Python great thanks
son so this is aimed more at those of
you who are maybe newer to the whole
machine learning deep learning data
space here which I am relatively
speaking so though I'm a PhD in health
services research it was just a couple
years ago that I started learning Python
and about six months ago that I started
embarked on a deep learning course which
i think is like super cool never thought
I would have anything to do deep
learning because it's not really in my
lot in my area which is which is
healthcare but I liked it so I thought I
would just share some of that today I
kind of lied to Sean and I told him I
was gonna talk about the deep learning
library but I'm also going to talk about
the MOOC which is where it came from so
yeah my affiliation so I'm with the US
Department of Veterans Affairs for the
next eight days after which I'll be
moving to jewel health
so where's fast day I come from and kind
of what's the idea so this is a
brainchild of Jeremy Howard who some of
you may know from the capital
competitions he was CEO for a while he
also has started up a analytic company
called analytic that did early
applications of deep learning to
medicines radiological images and
reading those and he is now moved over
to teaching he founded fast is a way to
kind of democratize the education of
deep learning and people making it more
accessible to people so what he has is
both kind of an in-person course and
then whenever he runs in person course
even packages that up as a MOOC
afterwards and puts it completely online
so it's a couple of seven week courses
that he offers I'm doing the the live
virtual versions but the online versions
are great too
some of the things that are great about
it number one free free is good number
two there's a large community of
learners from all over the world
participating in it so you've always got
a couple 300 people there learning
alongside you and there to answer
questions on the forums and very willing
to share their knowledge which is a
great resource when you're someone like
me who always likes having someone to
ask a question of okay and so a little
bit more about MOOC and I'll talk a
little bit about the library so starts
off with some basic convolutional neural
networks image classification moves on
to some NLP with recurrent neural
networks with a real emphasis on
applying things first kind of seeing how
things work first and then popping up in
the hood and looking underneath and
saying let's look at the code let's look
at at the algorithms what's going on
here to help people understand more
what's behind the whole deep learning
thing and what makes a neural network
different from say a typical machine
learning kind of process very big
emphasis on practical things so less
although he does this time talk a bit
more about you know how you read papers
that are out in the literature and some
of the new things they're coming up very
much emphasis on practical things just
you know high parameter tuning and and
best practices around things like that
but also the idea of transfer learning
which some so transfer learning being
the idea that somebody's already trained
a network on something of a large
database of images and that you then
take what they've done take the
parameters that they've learned and then
just apply it to your own problem by
making tweaks to what they're doing so
you may have a model that's been trained
on thousands of images of all kinds of
different animals and then you turn
around and say well I'm just interested
in distinguishing a dog from a cat so
I'll take this network I'll chop off the
end of it and then I'll just use it
retrain it a little bit to distinguish
dogs from cats so a lot of success in
doing that it's not a well depending
some people don't think that's a they
make it's cheating
it's kind of a too easy way to do it but
so and so it's kind of nice because the
because he's trying to make it
accessible it's not oriented towards
people who have PhDs in math it's all
right [ __ ] towards people who can
understand an excel file and see you
know you can apply that you can say I'm
applying a convolutional filter here and
you can see the calculation right in the
spreadsheet so definitely trying to make
it again accessible to those of us who
took calculus a long long time ago so
along with this he's kind of built up a
library of helpers tools for both
machine learning and for deep learning
it's kind of additional layers of
abstraction that are built on top of
scikit-learn for the machine learning
and pi torch for the deep learning also
a Spacey for NLP applications so he's
kind of you know adding some stuff
around the edges it just makes it a
little easier to work with so there's
that said he's kind of not dumbing it
down and that he seems to be pretty on
top of the literature so there's some
neat things that he has to offer like
new methods for quick ways to find a
rate that's pretty good learning rate to
use for training your network different
things like that also lots of like
pre-processing tools data augmentation
tools tools for pre-processing text or
time series data other structured data
which he also likes to feed into neural
networks so so for someone who's kind of
coming into this and pretty much
interested more in application rather
than like developing your own algorithm
or you know getting a PhD in this type
of field it's a nice set of tools to
have very accessible great community of
people and you know it's kind of fun to
be able to train a network to 99.1%
accuracy in three lines of code so I
present you with just fast AI and if
you're interested in the MOOC or any
information on that feel free to just
tell me down afterwards
thank you yeah
fast data and get you to their blog
space and there's a link to the MOOC
other questions
have you tried some of the other
libraries and it's like based on this is
just like much easier to use or a little
easier to use or how is the user
experience so I couldn't really make it
through the pipe torch documentation on
my own so for me it was a much enhanced
experience to do this for some of the
others might not be as much of a value
added in terms of Spacey or some of the
other libraries that might be a little
more user friendly but I think for that
kind of a gut so the deep learning or
someone like me at least it was let's
think marina yes all right
tonight is Jeremy McManus and he's going
to be talking to us about an airflow ETL
on Amazon AWS thanks Sean so my name is
Jeremy and I'm kind of a data engineer
and a data scientist and so like the
part that I'm going to talk to you about
today is kind of there are things that
happen I think this is a slide show so
give me a second I don't want to do a
slide show so the things that I'm going
to talk to you today are some of the
things that happened before you get to
do some of the data science that you'd
like to do and so you know as a start-up
guy the way that this works is that I'll
go somewhere and like you have like a
database that lives somewhere that your
application uses people start asking you
questions to do analytics on it and
you'll have to get that data somewhere
you can make it useful so what I'm going
to show you is Apache airflow and how
you can use it to do an ETL process
which is a tract extract transform and
load on the nay ws platform so the data
team needs data you can't do what you
want to do what they paid you to bring
here and you just can't do it unless
somebody gets you the data and so all
the good stuff that's trapped in your
apps production database so what we're
going to do is we're going to try to get
it out without crashing the app and
without getting fired
so the problems typically are that your
application database is really optimized
for doing transactional things right so
you want to go and update rows whereas
what we need to do is we need to do
analytics on it so we need columns right
maybe you don't have a read clone maybe
you do have reclone but it's a Wimpy one
so as soon as you start querying it
everything just stops you can't pull
your data straight off the production
because somebody's going to call you and
tell you that you're in trouble so the
solution is is most engineering teams
will take a daily backup of their
production database so after that
happens it's nobody's you can take it
you can spin it up and then you can use
that data in order to pull it somewhere
else and do your analytics so we're
going to restore the snapshot each day
we're going to load the data from it
into s3 where you keep your files copy
it to redshift and we're going to do all
this using air flow so these are the
different pieces that I'm going to show
you I'm going to show you a little bit
about air flow a little bit about AWS
data ecosystem how the data gets flowed
and then just a little bit of code so R
is anybody here on AWS does anybody
familiar with okay great
yeah so RDS is the relational database
service it's a hosted version of the
databases you know and love my favorite
flavor is Postgres but if you love
another flavor you could use it to
redshift is a column store it speaks
about the same language as Postgres does
except for it's built to do analytics it
takes some tuning it's not too bad to
learn if you're interested we can talk
about it Apache airflow is a project
that was started at Aaron B&B several
years ago it was really one of the first
kind of data engineering projects that
I'm aware of outside of the kind of
Hadoop ecosystem so it's all
like a Python 2.7 project it provides
you a bunch of building blocks operators
and tasks that are easy to extend in
Python and you use this to build
directed acyclic graphs so very similar
to the picture that you have for a snake
Bank it the very nice things about it
from an engineering perspective is it
gives you visibility if something goes
wrong you get an email or a slack
message you can go back and you can look
at your audit logs you can see the
history of what's been happening how
long it's been taking really understand
what your your data flow is doing so
here in the picture on the top right and
the picture of a dag these can be simple
or complex just a series of steps that
it goes through here's a piece of
monitoring this is mine so they're all
green then this is the kind of
historical set of the different tags
that run sometimes they fail that turns
red you can see them so this is the kind
of basic data flow if you're a very
early stage in a startup and all you
want to do is every day get your data
out so every morning RDS is going to
take a snapshot it's going to get put on
the AWS air flow is going to pull until
that snapshot is available you're going
to restore it you're going to take that
RDS instance and you're going to copy
all of the data to disk when you copy it
to disk one of the really nice things
that you can do is you can select things
off of the tables you can do joins you
can do functions anything that you can
do in Postgres easily this is the time
to do it because it's not so easy once
it gets to redshift always be aware of
changing schema it'll keep you up at
night then from air flow what you'll do
is you send that data to s3 when it's on
s3 you can split it into chunks then
from s3 you copy it into redshift
redshift there's some nice things that
you can do whenever you're moving it
over like analyzing and compressing the
data again be aware of changing schema
and this is just kind of an example dag
that's a little bit of code here on the
right hand side we
have the dag definition so you're
directed acyclic graph has a series of
steps this bottom picture right here the
dag flow it's just a simple linear set
of steps so you check for a snapshot you
delete the old roll over database you
wait for the new roll over to be
available you restore the snapshot you
modify it by applying any modifications
that you need you reboot the database
wait until it's ready and then you
continue downstream this is a task it's
written in Python you can read it it's
very straightforward and the very middle
of it there's a get recent snapshots
that's a boat oh call and that's that's
the meat of it the rest of it is just
air handling and like telling you that
you need to wait a little bit longer and
that's it so I hope to provide a
template or code sample soon I know that
this is kind of more on the data science
and the data engineering side but if
you're interested in it then this is
like a pretty clean framework in order
to do ETL so airflow has a couple of
different ways that you can do this one
of them is that you can have like a meso
s-- like cluster you can use cuber
Nettie's but it's a local disk you can
do it on node if you just have small
amounts of data you can handle
concurrency and all those other things
to the configuration in order to not
overwhelm your disk
this one yes this is the app production
database and you have a daily snapshot
that gets stored in the AWS cloud that
you then restore AWS does that
automatically so redshift there's two
ways that you can load data why
of them is by like values but the other
way is using a CSV and so the CSV for
redshift is built to accept data off of
s3 this is a requirement for using
redshift on top so I believe it was like
Postgres 8/3 somewhere around there
redshift forked so there was a company
that built a multi processing plat
column store on top of Postgres and then
got bought and that's what that's why
they're so similar yeah so I don't I
don't know how to do that so what you
can do you can do like a PG dump you can
so you have no kitchen no you have to
put data in s3 to get it in redshift air
flow provides scheduling monitoring if I
just had a direct command that I could
issue to move data from RDS to redshift
I would do it in a heartbeat
and I would schedule it with air flow
and air flow would tell me when it
failed and send me an email
yes so I I have part of the work of
doing a SAS company is that you have to
build user sessions and every morning I
have an air flow job that goes in and
runs a sequel query on top of my
database in order to session eyes all of
the new user data I think William
Nerine for giving us a wonderful talk
today please stick around interactive
ask questions to our speakers